in the movie you got to kiss James
Franco yeah I say got to because it's
every man's dream about you know the day
of when when we were shooting that scene
I you know it wasn't a big deal to me
I'm an actor I'm a professional you know
it was just you know it's a nice moment
in the movie we're gonna kiss that's
fine
you know I wasn't nervous or anything
but and then when we shot the scene and
our lips met something about that guy is
just magical you know I mean his lips
are like really soft and I don't it just
like stayed with me you know like the
moment stayed with me and I couldn't let
go of it yeah yeah and like in the next
few days I was just like thinking about
it and wondering if it stayed with him -
yeah and then and then like like a week
later I found out that he actually like
made a painting he does paintings with
people yeah and Seth Rogen's been on the
show and shown paintings that he's done
if Safin yeah yeah he doesn't he did one
of me and I don't know if we have yeah
oh look at ya know if you could I mean
if you if you look at the lips right I
don't know what that says to you but it
tells me that he that kiss stayed with
him - yeah he really accentuate